Ron could stand up say three sentences
he could walk up and just go how now
brown cow the quick brown fox jumps over
the lazy dog leave and then they can
make him say anything they want I am not
actually suggesting that's what they did
it's just I mean you thought the same
thing it would he talks like this and
then he'll go on to say another sentence
and then he'll continue like this it
felt very
robotic I think was that not the problem
of his entire KY like a
is a crucial factor in politics uh and
running for governor is not the same as
running for president running for
government you can keep the media at Bay
you have to give that many interviews
you can control access to yourself much
tougher to do that when you're running
for president uh and in this particular
case this guy spent
$300
million uh and he dropped out of New
Hampshire because he had dropped below
5% of the vote